we're seeing by my estimate probably a
tenfold increase in attitudes towards
political violence now compared to
before donald trump was president
there's domestic terrorism
investigations in all 50 states one in
10 americans believe donald trump should
be forcibly reinstalled in the white
house
and another one in 10 americans say they
do believe violence against the
government
is justified it's a really really
alarming environment and one of the
blinking red indicators
of why a pressure release valve is
needed in our political system so what i
experienced uh coming out and speaking
out against trump is in fact one of the
reasons why
i grew
much more open to the idea
of a new way in our political system and
the need for a new party
[Music]
it is my pleasure and thrill to welcome
to forward the co-ceo of the new ford
party new york times best-selling author
patriot american whom i call the bad boy
of american politics you'll see why he
earned that moniker miles taylor welcome
miles
well for those who are watching on video
i tried to do a superman fly over the
camera but it looked more like me just
trying to show my belly buttons it must
look like you're stretching but it's all
to the good
uh well it's it's been an awesome week
or so for us uh with the announcement of
forward party wow have we sent
shockwaves and tremors throughout the
beltway throughout
more importantly throughout homes and
workplaces and diners around the country
uh what's the last week been like for
you
i mean it's been crazy i think in a lot
of ways this
really exceeded expectations in just the
first 48 hours andrew we had
uh 40 million americans that we reached
on television and radio alone i think we
pulled in something like 20 000 plus new
volunteers inside the organization
across all 50 states
and again that was just in the first two
days we're now about a week out from our
announcement and i think those numbers
are a lot higher and that was the goal
is to let americans know basically help
is on the way there's a new option in
our political system
and uh we're seeing folks come out in
throats because they're frustrated and
and that's really what the theme i think
for the past week has been is that
people are really really frustrated with
the current system i think i saw a poll
the other day that showed 90
of americans are unhappy with the
direction the country is going and
that's partly because the existing
outdated sort of stagnating two-party
system is actually just not solving our
problems so no wonder people are pissed
off um and that was another headline
this morning is that
i think it was in the new york times
they did a focus group with something
like seven republicans and six democrats
and the theme was there actually was
common ground between democrats and
republicans and it was that they're
pissed off at the stats yes um i think
that's very telling and that's why we
need something new yeah we need some
positive change uh to hopefully frankly
balance some of the negative changes we
see
occurring around us so how the heck did
you get to this point because i think
most everyone who's
in independent politics uh has a bit of
a story and you have a better story than
just about anybody so when i say that
you're the new york times bestselling
author you were better known as
anonymous
because you wrote
a book from within the trump
administration and getting out of the
trump administration
you faced threats to your personal
safety uh like great personal costs
uh how the heck did you get to this
point you know look it it
no one has to play the violin for me
that
things got really rough and tumble in
the political system but but i will take
you back in time and talk about how i
wound up there because
i don't even think my story makes sense
that i'm now working in independent
politics in fact i never wanted to work
in politics i hated campaigns i hated
the political side i was a policy guy
not a politics guy and after 9 11 i went
into government because
i'd been in the world trade center two
weeks before the attacks and and in the
weeks after was diagnosed with mild
post-traumatic stress disorder i had
taken
the news of that day so so personally
and seriously uh and traumatically that
i resolved that what i wanted to do was
spend the rest of my career in national
security and make sure a day like that
never happened that took me on an
odyssey through washington from capitol
hill to the pentagon to the white house
ultimately i ended up at the department
of homeland security department that was
created
to prevent another another 911. so i
worked there during the bush
administration as a as a briefer to the
secretary you know working on a range of
intelligence issues and then after the
bush administration ended i went uh back
to capitol hill and worked in a number
of national security roles
up until donald trump ran for president
in 2015. now i was a lifelong republican
and we saw trump more as an oddity than
anything but he went from an oddity
to a major worry
to a calamity in 2016 when he did the
unthinkable and he won and i was working
as a again as a national security aide
in the house republican leadership at
the time
had no interest in going into
the trump administration but
you know in the in fact had worked
pretty extensively to try to keep him
from getting elected in fact i was the
co-author of what paul ryan had termed
the trump inoculation plan behind closed
doors at the time which clearly failed
miserably it failed spectacularly
because not only did we not inoculate
the republican party against trump he
took it over and he won so i decided i
wasn't going to go into the
administration but then uh a mentor of
mine someone i looked up to john kelly
was picked to be homeland security
secretary
uh and and basically said to me it's not
as bad as it looks inside the trump
administration it's a lot worse
and i was persuaded to come in and be
his national security advisor ultimately
became chief of staff at dhs
and in short andrew you know what i saw
really terrified me i had hoped at the
beginning that donald trump would have
been someone who the office
moderated a lot of presidents barack
obama george w bush talk about how the
oval office changed them
um i was hopeful that that would happen
with donald trump maybe even a little
naive
and it didn't and from day one it was
clear not only that this administration
was turbulent but that it was a as one
cabinet secretary said behind closed
doors a threat to the fabric of our
republic so
uh you know ultimately i wrote a piece
an essay in the new york times
explaining what the president's own
people were saying about how dangerous
he was because i felt like there was a
lot of talking heads saying that donald
trump was reckless but
that was one thing was another thing for
his own
senior leaders in his cabinet
to be wondering whether they should
invoke the 25th amendment and get rid of
him because he was so dangerous and i
felt like people needed to know that so
happy to talk about that experience but
ultimately that led me to to quit the
trump administration unmask myself and
and campaign against him so that he
wouldn't be reelected
well certainly i'd love to hear about
your experience you must have been
paranoid and freaked out where you write
this essay and then everyone's like who
wrote that who wrote that what the heck
is going on um that must have been an
extraordinarily stressful difficult set
of experiences yeah you know i a couple
of things i mean i want to comment on
anonymity
because a lot of people rightfully
questioned my decision to write that
essay
anonymously and part of my inspiration
behind that was and i'm not comparing
myself to these people but was the
founding fathers
we saw
around the time
that the continental congress was trying
to get the uh
you know the constitution passed in the
united states a group of people
who called themselves publius and they
wrote a series of essays defending the
constitution that was a number of
founding fathers including alexander
hamilton and john jay
the reason they hid their names was not
because they were scared to put their
names out there but it's because they
knew if they attached their names to
those essays defending the constitution
the critics would make it more about
them than about the substance so they
hid their names to make people focus on
the message and not the messenger now in
the time that i was in the trump
administration it became very clear to
me that donald trump was a master of the
politics of personal destruction and
distraction right he would create a
personal fight to distract from his own
deficiency
so i
decided i submitted this essay to the
times and i said you know i want to use
a pseudonym and i actually asked them to
use the pseudonym publius and the time
said well we don't do pseudonyms so
we'll just we'll just put anonymous but
the reason i wanted them to use the
public pseudonym is for a discerning
student of history i wanted them to see
the connection to understand
why
i was not exposing my name but my plan
come on new york times except pseudonyms
it'd be so much cooler come on you could
like you you know you could write max
power
you could do
publius you could do
whatever the heck you want come on times
let's spice this up well you know i'll
say one thing andrew which is that you
know i expressed publicly i later wrote
a book also anonymously called a warning
to write a longer form
explanation of why i didn't think the
commander-in-chief based on my personal
experiences
deserved a second term and in fact why i
thought he was exceptionally dangerous
for this country but i ultimately
pledged that i was going to unmask
myself and i did and i don't want to
i don't want to demean people
who blow the whistle
and want to maintain anonymity in fact
there's a very patriotic person who's
still anonymous
who uh blew the whistle on donald
trump's ukraine phone call you know the
perfect phone call he said he made that
he was impeached over i respect that
person's decision to maintain
anonymity uh but i'll be honest with you
i personally felt like
if i did that
uh and i had an opportunity to go out
and campaign against him and i kept the
mask on that ultimately it would be
cowardly
and you know people may be surprised to
hear anonymous say anonymity is cowardly
um i don't think that's always the case
i thought it would have been in my case
if i didn't
come forward and here's why because a
lot of the things that i had to say
about why donald trump was unqualified
for office
could not be said with a mascot
because i had to be specific i needed to
detail meetings things he said things he
did and that required stepping out of
the shadows but to your question andrew
um you know i had a conversation with
someone i was very close to at the time
one of the very few people who knew
that i was this you know this pseudonym
this this this character anonymous and
the person close to me said you know
what's the worst that could happen if
you come forward and i said well you
know a manga person could come up in the
street and you know pop me and that
would be that and that sounds very
dramatic but honestly our political
environment was getting so tumultuous at
that time and this i think only got
worse that expecting a violent reaction
almost made the most sense so the person
says back to me okay well what's the
second worst thing that could happen i
said well
you know i could lose my home my job my
personal relationships my friendships my
you know family security my life savings
um you know it could get really ugly
it turned out at least knock on wood so
far andrew to be the second scenario now
again i say that not because i want any
sympathy i don't want sympathy from
anyone i went into this clear-eyed
but i say it because the environment
we're in today
is an environment of enormous political
intimidation so someone like me from the
national security community was pretty
well prepared as as prepared as you
could possibly be
to be on the receiving end of a
vitriolic commander-in-chief
hell-bent on revenge and an army of maga
people coming forward to come after him
but the poll worker
the community leader the school board
member the people we've heard from the
january 6 select committee hearings
those people weren't prepared
for the consequences of speaking out and
now it's happening to everyday
americans that's what i worry about and
i'll add some data to this uh
and that is you know we're seeing by my
estimate probably a tenfold increase in
attitudes towards political violence now
compared to before donald trump was
president there's domestic terrorism
investigations in all 50 states in every
single fbi field office in the country
one in 10 americans believe donald trump
should be forcibly reinstalled in the
white house
and another one in 10 americans say they
do believe violence against the
government
is justified it's a really really
alarming environment and one of the
blinking red indicators
of why a pressure release valve is
needed in our political system so what i
experienced uh coming out and speaking
out against trump is in fact one of the
reasons why
i grew
much more open to the idea of a new way
in our political system and the need for
a new party is because i think a lot of
the vitriol we're seeing is driven by
the fact that people feel like there are
no alternatives in the political system
there's no peaceful way for them to
convey their political opinions and
folks are being radicalized to violence
it's really alarming from a national
security perspective but just in terms
of the health of our democracy
uh is is incredibly disturbing i saw it
firsthand and it's one of the reasons
why after january 6th rather than go
back to the private sector which i think
everyone in my family wished i would do
i decided to stay in the political fight
and now a word from our sponsor better
help starting a third party is super
exciting but i gotta say it's sometimes
a little bit stressful i do my best to
take care of myself my mental health i
try and exercise i try to get some
outdoor time but sometimes you need a
bit more than that sometimes you need
out and out therapy
i saw a counselor for the first time
when i was a teen and i've been a big
believer in therapy
ever since better help is online therapy
that offers video phone and live chat
only therapy sessions so you don't have
to see anyone on camera if you're not
into that it's more affordable you can
be matched with your own therapist in
under 48 hours take care of yourself
invest in your own mental health which
really is the same thing as health and
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
yang that's better h-e-l-p-com
yang
[Music]
well hats off to you for
being so courageous i mean the fact is
uh most people have no idea what it's
like to to think that their
life could be threatened
uh it puts me
uh to thinking about the republican
members of congress who were voting to
impeach trump and what i was told was
that something like 35 of them said yeah
i'm going to vote to impeach trump this
is a bridge too far and then they all
started getting messages including death
threats on their phones and then the 35
went to 30 to 25 to 20. and then by the
time the vote actually happened it was
down to 10 and even those 10 had no idea
who else was going to vote
uh for impeachment and by the way now i
believe
uh seven of those ten are uh out of
office one of them peter meyer just lost
his primary
um and his extremist election-denying
republican opponent was boosted by
democrats which angers me i mean how can
you say hey i'm for democracy on one
side but i'm going to spend hundreds of
thousands or even millions of dollars
boosting someone i i think is
uh trying to completely upend the system
and so i think about those members
including peter and some of them had to
go into hiding for a period of days
after because there was so much venom
being directed toward them most people
have no idea what it's like to be on the
receiving end of that and the fact that
i mean you're making light of it you're
like hey it's not about me it's about
the fact that our country is in trouble
as a system but really just want to
salute you and your courage because most
people wouldn't have been able to do it
well i i appreciate that andrew and
you know i i try to tell those stories
so people can viscerally live in it i
mean you know the day
that the election was held
uh on you know november 3rd 2020 a lot
of people were
you know out and about jubilantly hoping
the election would result the way they
wanted to i spent most of that night
holed up in a safe house in virginia
with an armed bodyguard right that
wasn't exactly a lot of fun now i did
make it out of the house uh you know i
had a driver that you know i was i was
lucky to have protection i couldn't
afford it i was very lucky that someone
helped me for a period of time get
protection because of the death threats
um but yeah you know that's that's not
where i had imagined myself on election
day when donald trump was defeated but
that was a result of the really really
graphic
messages not just i received but you
know my pregnant sister my father my
mother
my cousins i mean this is an environment
where anyone thinks
they can
uh have you know and have the right to
reach out and and punch you or hit your
or threaten you it's um
and we've seen the extrapolation of that
into our political system and i mean as
you know andrew after
the january sixth insurrection members
that voted to impeach donald trump i
know a number of members of congress who
were going to vote to impeach him
and change their votes because of
intimidation these aren't made up
stories liz cheney went out there and
publicly talked about how friends of
hers in congress would have voted to
impeach but said look i'm worried about
my family members lives that's not how
american democracy works i i can't even
believe we're talking about
a point in american history where our
congressmen are voting a certain way
because they actually are scared if they
vote their conscience they will be
killed that that's it's a seems like a
hyperbolic thing to say
um but it's also not just an aberration
it wasn't just a point in time since
that day
we have seen assassination plots against
u.s governors
against sitting members of congress
against a united states senator just the
other week we had a congresswoman who
had a crazed man with a loaded gun go
stand outside her house uh and and make
threats this is happening and again the
light is blinking red from a public
safety standpoint um and it's really
alarming it's one of the reasons we have
to take action we haven't seen anything
like this
in modern history or this level of
division
we've got to do something about it uh
but you know i worry the trend lines are
headed the wrong direction you mentioned
peter meyer
losing his seat you know a number of
these members of congress who stood up
and did the right thing
didn't even have to be taken out by a
maga extremist they took themselves out
because they knew they looked at the
numbers and knew
that with the trump takeover of the
republican party it was not possible for
them to go win re-election in the
districts that they had won handily in
previous cycles they just they just knew
they couldn't possibly do it so um i
think anyone who looks at the republican
party today and says that the
rational side is winning against the
radical side must be huffing something
that i've never heard of because the the
rational side the so-called rebels in
the gop
are losing they're losing very badly the
the war for the soul
of the republican party is being won by
the trump maga base and again it's
another symptom
of a much deeper rot inside the
political system yeah it's one reason
why you and i are working together to
try and upgrade and revamp the two-party
system because the fact is if you have
one party go dark as the republican
party has then you can be subject to
terrible political incentives and
intimidation and authoritarianism pretty
quickly it's a very very vulnerable
susceptible system whereas if you had a
more robust multi-party system it's much
much harder so so you are under armed
guard for your safety you leave the
administration uh the private sector
beckons but you say you know what i'm
not done fighting for the country so
then you join uh renew america which uh
is trying to help moderate our politics
but i think in particular was investing
uh to try and keep trumpism from taking
over the republican party uh
wha what has your experience been like
at renu
[Music]
and how did you get to a point where you
said you know what we should join forces
with sam and ford and form the biggest
third party
buy resources
in the country the best chance in a
generation
for
a challenge to the two-party system
watching netflix without using
expressvpn honestly it's like going to a
casino and only playing slots like i'm a
blackjack guy i'm a craps guy that's
where the big money is even roulette at
times the big money's elsewhere and
that's what it's like if you're using a
streaming app and not using expressvpn
so here's the deal netflix has different
content libraries for every country
they've got thousands of shows but
without a vpn like expressvpn you only
get access to a fraction of that based
on your location so what you can do with
expressvpn to unblock this content is
that you can change your online location
control where you want netflix or other
streaming websites to think you're
located so
for example
i love the office i love falling asleep
to an episode of the office the us
version with michael scott with steve
carell's michael scott you can't get
that on netflix anymore however
if i tell netflix that i'm streaming
from canada
i can get
the office on my netflix on my smart tv
or on my computer
no problem so expressvpn over other vpns
why use them they're super fast you can
stream in hd with no buffering it's
compatible with all your devices i love
that i put it on my roku tv i put it on
my phone my laptop whatever it is and
you get 94 different countries right
it's literally thousands of new shows
you want to watch something foreign you
can do that too so here's the deal i
want you to be smart i want you to stop
paying full price for streaming services
and only getting access to less than the
full amount of their content so get your
money's worth at expressvpn.com
yang don't forget to use our link
thank you andrew yang and team
expressvpn.com
yang that's
expressvpn.com yang to get an extra
three months of expressvpn for free
[Music]
this actually gets into what we're all
about andrew because i i think that
just meeting you and getting to know you
is a microcosm of this larger story
because you and i don't agree on a lot
of policy issues
and you know
in any other circumstance in any other
period in time it wouldn't necessarily
make sense for us to form a political
coalition and i'll get to that in a
minute um but my first inclination after
january 6 was you know we've got to go
try to save the republican party and it
sounds incredibly naive a year and a
half later
but that was my perspective is we've got
to save the republican party hoping that
donald trump was an aberration
and i get a call the day after january
6. true story is i get a phone call from
my good friend evan mcmullen and evan
had worked with me in the house of
representatives
and in 2016 some people may remember
evan got so fed up with the fact that no
sane republican was stepping forward to
try to stop trump's candidacy they'd all
kind of just become compliant and
complicit in his run thinking that he
wouldn't win and uh you know but
it would all be fine in the end
and evan was worried everyone was like
no i don't think this guy is inevitably
going to lose i think he's a threat to
democracy and so evan went and ran as a
third party candidate for president now
we you know evan didn't win but the hope
was they might be able to try to take
trump out or deny him a couple of states
and uh i stayed in touch with evan
through the years he started some
pro-democracy efforts and after january
6 you know evan knew i was thinking
about just stepping back now that trump
had been defeated but the insurrection
pointed to something much scarier
happening in our political system and
evan said look don't tap out come come
be involved in this with me let's see if
we can
swing the pendulum back to the center so
we convened a group of 150 or 200
prominent republicans some former
governors and senators and congressmen
and cabinet secretaries i mean really
you know top republicans who had stood
against trump some of whom who didn't
but wanted to see the party go back to
normal and we put a question to them and
we said what needs to be done right now
do we either go try to fix the gop and
swing the pendulum back or is it time
for a third way like do we need to go
actually start a new party and the group
was evenly split we actually sent out a
poll on this giant zoom call like the
most unwieldy zoom call you've ever been
on at these you know a couple hundred
people and it was a 50 50 split half the
group said no it's time to go start a
new political party the gop can't be
saved um and evan and i aired on the
side of caution we said look let's give
it a shot and we launched renewamerica
movement with a bunch of these former
prominent republicans to go try to
protect the good guys the rational
republicans against the bad guys the
radical ones who were denying the
election promoting conspiracy theories
promoting political violence
and i think what we saw in that
year-long process
uh was
it
not only was the strategy
uh failing
but that the the magazine was really on
the ascent in a sense trump playing king
maker has made a thousand mini trumps
across this country and they've far
accelerated ahead of the pro-democracy
side
in you know going and running for office
and winning elections and advancing
forward and it became clear to us that
you know trump maintained a darth
vader-like chokehold
over the republican party and so
that takes us to you know
last fall i had heard andrew that you
were
potentially starting
a new party effort and i remember
having
what people call fomo i had fear of
missing out because i was starting to
think maybe this quest
to fix the gop
was doomed to fail maybe things were a
lot worse than i realized
and um
and i was excited about that
announcement and you and i a few months
later
ended up at the same meeting together in
new york city of a group of folks who
you know came from across the political
spectrum but all of whom were investing
in independent races and at that point
my friend evan mcmullen had left gone
back to utah and was running uh for you
know us senate in utah and evan's still
running for senate now
and he was doing it as an independent
candidate and not as a republican and it
offered a really unique opportunity to
try to go win back a senate seat for a
pro-democracy person this evan mcmullen
race is the most important senate race
in the country let's go evan mcmullen
continue and i'm sure we're going to
talk about in detail it is the most
important race this cycle in the country
evan's running as an independent against
mike lee who helped uh you know back the
insurrection and an effort to overturn
the 2020 election results and um you
know when we all got together in new
york and and had a conversation these
groups like us that were investing in
races like evans and other independents
uh there was a light bulb moment i think
one of us at the table andrew you know
might have been you might have been me
uh might have been someone there at
lunch said
why don't we just stop talking about
informally
working together to promote independent
candidacies let's go do something bigger
why don't we actually merge and try to
go build a new lane that that was me but
continue
[Laughter]
i stand corrected
the only way to restore sanity to the
system is to offer me offer people more
choices more choice and competition and
i'll say andrew i've said it a million
times but it bears repeating
that right now
all of us have unlimited choice
and competition in almost every aspect
of our lives like rideshare food
delivery clothes like we talk about this
all the time i i can choose from
whatever option i want in almost
everything ironically the one place that
in school i was told uh was all about
choice and competition our democracy
ironically i don't have choice and
competition anymore i've got two
outdated choices
and uh increasingly they're getting more
and more extreme now you know folks will
jump in and say but wait you know
don't do the both sides is them they're
not both equally bad i will be the first
to say
that i think my former party the
republican party has gone further off
the deep end in representing a danger to
democracy that's why i've gone out this
cycle to help
pro-democracy democrats win elections i
never thought as a former republican i'd
be out there trying to help you know
moderate republi or democrats win
elections but that's why i've done it is
because we've got to keep the trump gop
at bay
but what worries me
is what you just noted is that also on
the democratic side there's some really
reckless behavior there's not only
democrats that i know who work for the
president at the highest levels of the
white house are saying our party's being
overtaken by the fringes but we're also
seeing democrats invest
in
trumpy republicans because they think
it's their best way
to tee up one of their candidates like
hey let's put party over country let's
play politics and elevate like a doug
mastriano in pennsylvania who by the way
last i checked is actually pulling
competitively yeah um so i mean i'd say
this guys this is how trump got elected
i mean do people not remember in 2016
democrats thought it was hilarious that
our party had this carnival barker go
from number 17 in the race to number one
they thought it was hilarious and not
only that there were there was dark
democratic money that went in
to push
you know donald trump forward or at
least to knock down his competitors
because he was viewed as the weakest
candidate against hillary clinton well
we all know how that story ended that
was not an aberration but we're seeing
that same playbook happen across the
country and it's really disturbing to me
it's it's a symptom of the two-party
system man it's like hey i'm gonna do
something it's gonna be smart politics
check it out i'm going to like kneecap
the moderate and then have the more
beatable candidate in the general it's
like oh no i lost the more beautiful
extremists like oh you know
i mean you asked for it you're playing
with fire and the democrats do it over
and over again in part because the
democratic party
uh
often i mean the utah democratic party
was an exception where they put country
over party and they said hey we're going
to get out of the way and
give evan a chance to win this thing
but in other contexts the democrats will
definitely just say look
um we're going to play politics we're
going to boost the extremists we're
going to kick a minor party off the
ballot if we think it's going to help us
we're going to fight a rank choice
voting initiative we think it's bad for
our interests uh and it does frustrate
the heck out of me when the democrats
present themselves it's like we're
championing democracy it's like well you
know democracy doesn't just mean voting
for you
like that democracy
means people being able to vote how they
want so maybe you know more open system
would be good you said something to me
that made me laugh but we might as well
share it so i publicly left the
democratic party which by the way was a
much bigger deal than i thought it was
going to be i was just like well i guess
if i'm going to start this other thing i
should leave the democratic party and
then it ended up being all those news
and headlines um you left the republican
party uh and uh i know and i would not
compare our two experiences because you
were you know uh had under like threat
to your life and a bunch of other things
in a way that i was not so one thing you
said to me was was that hey you have
press requests all the time from msnbc
and cnn as like the former republican
and you may not know this but i get
press requests every day from fox and
conservative outlets
where like they really like having the
person who left the other party
on
um
sorry i just thought that you might find
that entertaining yeah you know but it's
also i think it's a statement about
what's happened i mean honestly you and
i both have this experience andrew we've
been weaponized by one side against the
other right because they think it's such
a novelty these defectors but to them
we're not a novelty because we represent
the majority of americans who actually
want an alternative it's because they
just want to use an ex-republican or an
ex-democrat to bludgeon the other side
and and that's you know uh
funny at first but then
you know you ultimately end up feeling a
little bit used by that and honestly the
thing that most convinced me
uh that we needed a third way in our
political system
in all seriousness
was just because i want i want that
i want that as a voter i'm just a i'm
just a voter it's like you know you're
you're our own customer i got you man
and you think there must be millions of
people like me if i wanted there must be
others yeah people who build cool
products airpods iphones whatever and
i'm not trying to hawk apple but i'm a
big apple fan you know people go build
those products build them because they
want them they they need
those products and and the marketplace
is not offering that
i
desperately wish there was an
alternative to the
trumpian republican party and the
increasingly fringe
democratic party but there isn't one and
so you know i went through a multi-month
period as we were starting conversations
with your organization personally
wrestling with this and talking to my
fiance and saying
you know is this uh
you know is is this something that we
have to go do is we have to go build it
is anyone else building it i think the
conclusion you and i came to andrew is
that
this conversation wasn't happening
anywhere else in the country
there was no
special secret room where people were
cooking up a plan to save america with a
third way even though americans
desperately wanted it and the numbers
say it we we should keep saying until
we're blue in the face half of the
country is now political independence
this is historic half the country 25 say
they're republicans 25 say they're
democrats and even those people who say
they're democrats and republicans
two-thirds of them say they want to see
a third party and they would vote for a
third party so let's go do that let's go
build that and and and that's what we're
trying to do um but that's what the
other thing that's exciting about this
to me is it's also cathartic
we all want
sort of the tensions in our political
system to cool and there's nothing like
shaking hands with someone that you
disagree with and having respect for
them and that's what this whole movement
is about i mean you know anytime you and
i see each other the second i see you
one i smile
and two i go up and i give you a big hug
it's like these two guys
who are totally on opposite ends of the
you know political spectrum one to the
right you know that's sort of
libertarian that's me you to the modern
you know left you know center left uh
but we we bump into each other and we
get excited because it's cathartic to
establish not just these friendships but
these partnerships across the aisle
because we know
that we respect each other's policy
disagreements and there's a space where
we can negotiate and find an outcome
that actually works whereas you know the
parties hunkered down in their corners
will just fight and fight and fight with
their fringe ideas but not actually
deliver i mean i lived this in the white
house on capitol hill and saw the total
inability to just get [ __ ] done um
that's what's fun about this for me is
we're building a movement that's all
about getting [ __ ] done and actually
putting forward solutions you know
what's funny miles i remember that
meeting uh at the end of last year that
first meeting
and we started to talk about merging our
organizations they're actually by the
way
uh for you listening to this there were
some other organizations that were in
consideration
um that
fell by the wayside maybe revisit who
the heck knows um but i i was strangely
optimistic the entire time that we were
going to come together
um despite knowing that this does not
happen
ordinarily
mergers are difficult and painful
everyone has
agendas and titles uh and turf to
protect
uh we were trying to combine three
organizations much less too
and
you know like as a business person
myself and i had some business people
advising me they would just look at that
being like a three-way merger this seems
like a terrible idea and i don't really
know what you're doing over there and
then i would have to say no no this is
different because you know it's not
corporations like you know that you're
used to and he was like okay they were
like okay okay um but i i found myself
very optimistic the entire time that we
were going to come together and i will
say now our having come together
has genuinely made a political history
where
now tens of millions of americans are
asking about the forward party when did
you have that confidence or did you have
that kind like where was your confidence
interval throughout the process where
you were like hey
like this is going to happen this isn't
going to happen when did it actually
click for you where like oh we're doing
this thing i i think it was some time in
the spring
and realizing
that
uh in the early spring late winter early
spring as
a lot of the races we were seeing across
the country that we were invested in at
renewamerica the so-called you know good
guys against the bad guys the
pro-democracy side against the election
deniers and conspiracy theorists as
those started to break bad and we saw
some real radicals get on the ballot i
mean major q anon supporters
violent figures convicted criminals um
that really cemented it for me that
there was no hope in trying to go
pull the extremes back to
you know the rational side that we had
to go create something new and that
there were deeper forces at play i mean
that really convinced me um but also you
know spending time with this cohort i
mean incredibly you know ram is a group
that was from the center right the
forward
original you know legacy forward party
from the center left and the surf
america movement folks
uh you know kind of a independent
centrist organization
and how well those groups were getting
along showed me that this was really
possible and i think we should be
unafraid to confront
the expected criticisms of a new way
like we're not spooked by that of course
people are gonna say
a new party's a spoiler and you can't
win and why have they failed in the past
um yeah we welcome those arguments
because we think the answers have
actually gotten really really good on
that front lawn the reason this is
different is the the political
environment's completely changed it's
completely changed from when ross perot
got 19 of the vote running for president
and this isn't about the presidential
right our effort is about going and
winning down ballot races across the
country the the 500 000 elected
positions around the united states that
are largely uncompetitive the other
thing that's changed is not only the
massive demand
that's much greater than when
we saw an independent candidate in 1992
win a ton of the popular vote um but is
the
uh is how extreme the two parties have
gotten i mean i you know we saw data
andrew that i think in 2020
on the ballot across the country
something like 70 percent of races in
2020 now it averages that lower uh
didn't have a competitor right didn't
have more than one person competing for
them that's because the two parties have
boxed out
competition and choice so
the situ you know the situation's got
more extreme politically consumers
voters want more options
and then you add to that uh i think a
very toxic political climate coming out
of the trump presidency and you almost
have the perfect storm for a new party
to emerge in this country
and actually give people a choice so
that's really exciting to me but to the
question of spoiler you know you hear
that and i just i gotta go back to the
example you gave of peter meyer in
michigan
um the two-party system is spoiled it's
already spoiled a system that doesn't
give you choices on the ballot is
spoiled in a system where one party is
actually boosting extremists because
they think it'll help their chances to
me
is really incredibly spoiled so
introducing a new option can only make
it better
well miles it's an intellectually
disingenuous question too because the
fact is if you're concerned about the
spoiler effect just adopt rank choice
voting and problem solved but then when
you say that to someone they're not like
oh thank you like let's go do that
instead it's like you know they're
they're not there to actually solve a
problem um they're there just to
say no no no uh you know um because like
that that's the conditioning and that's
the will of the institutions in a
country that by the way 88 of us think
is on the wrong track which is i think
one of the biggest
boosts that we're seeing
and the people are speaking i mean you
talked about the tens of thousands of
americans who are signing up for the
forward party we have some very exciting
announcements uh on the horizon i talked
to
uh your co-ceo matt shinners earlier
today and he told me that we have
volunteer events that had been up and
running around the country
and that their attendance at those
events has now spiked uh like five to
10x yeah um where like a group
that used to be like 12 people is now
like 120 people um so knowing that
that's happening around the country just
makes me so excited because the people
want this i mean it's it's ridiculous
that it's taking this long in some ways
i got a message from one of our
um
one of our leadership members inside the
organization who's actually upset
because they found out that there were
so many events being planned in their
home state
and they hadn't heard about them and i
said these are happening faster than i
can even keep up with so you know the
email that got forwarded that got
boarded that got boarded that landed in
my inbox i said i had no idea you know
ford members were organizing this event
because it's just happening so quickly
and
the other thing that we're seeing andrew
and i
you know we'll have some really exciting
announcements about this are people who
like us never expected that they would
become a part of a new party movement
who served in american politics i mean
former governors other presidential
candidates from both sides of the aisle
republican and democrat who've been
coming to us privately and saying
sign me up i'm in and you're going to
see some of these people going public
very soon you're going to see some of
them out there with us on the building
tour in the fall and going into the
winter we're going to be in
states all across the country talking
about how we're working to get ballot
access um but this is the real thing i
mean this is the thing that a lot of us
have been talking about for a very long
time like i think most listeners who are
on this podcast right now
have they do a barbecue or a dinner or a
conversation with friends or family
where you literally said
i just want a group that's like the i'm
not crazy coalition like can we just get
a sensible political party in this
country that gets things done could we
just have that like we've all had that
conversation and now it's time to just
go do it i'm so sick of talking about it
i'm so ready to just go build it and so
that's what we're doing we've got this
you know married band of former
republicans and democrats and
independents and by the way we're not
checking ids to see if people are
affiliated with one political party or
the other like that's the thing you can
you can be a republican and come join
the forward effort you can you can be a
republican and say yeah i'm getting
pretty sick of that tribe i want to go
be a part of a new one you can
definitely be a democrat and just say
hey just join the forward party i mean
the fact is you know yeah it's the water
is great it's okay no one's yeah no
one's making you switch no one's making
you change your id just come build it
with us and i also say that more
importantly than anyone andrew
uh is to critics you know we've seen
folks out there
who have responded to our announcement
in the new york times or the washington
post saying you know a third party is
needed but i don't know if these folks
have it right
i i want those people not not to just
debate us but to come be a part of this
to design it the way they think will
work that's what's really different
about this is we are actually inviting
critics of how we're doing things to
come be involved in our effort we're not
trying to butt heads with them we
actually want their heads to be in good
condition so they can come give us the
best advice possible on how to build
this that's really the funny thing too
miles it's like we're very positive and
constructive we attract positive
constructive people so if someone looks
up and it's like oh great like you know
i want to be a part of that then you can
come help build it define it lead it
you know come the tour join us at the
convention uh like help make this the
movement you want it to be
um that's one reason why we're we're
succeeding so well it's like we're
attracting these can do
uh roll up your sleeves types and then
if you're just someone who wants to be
on the side being like oh poo poo it
like guys i got to work it's like feel
free like you know i mean i i said to
someone else like watch us work and then
we're just like build it right in front
of you uh you know and and
uh and we're gonna just grow every
single day it's really magical i can't
tell you and people don't know this
necessarily because i don't
but
i'm very recognizable in public people
probably realize like hey you know
every day since our announcement a dozen
plus people have just come up to me and
been like hey man forward love it let's
go let's do it like with you with you
like everywhere i go people from every
walk of life like any livelihood any
location uh and that to me because i've
been a candidate before and you kind of
sense the energy around you the energy
around ford is sky high it is so awesome
uh and i love
um i love the positive incoming i even
love the negative incoming because like
you know like that the thing that we
we've done that we've surmounted
is that we've already become
something to be reckoned with we become
normalized uh and that's actually the
biggest challenge for a movement like
this that the fact is like move number
one
um is suppression
you know i mean it's like hey let's just
ignore you
uh which by the the way something like
sam has been dealing with for years uh
you know and so the fact that we
left that hurdle just a number of days
ago like now it's off to the races you
know andrew one of the things that i
want to say
in closing is that this is
this is an absolute new beginning for
this country politically is forward is
more than just a new political party it
really is a movement
to try to remake our politics it's an
exciting optimistic forward-looking
movement and it's not about
attacking one side or the other it
really is in our tagline not left not
right forward we are all about moving
past the extremes
finding common sense solutions and
getting things done that's what's so
exciting
about this for me and you know i'll say
when you look right now
at uh you know the things that are
happening in this country i think most
americans can reach
frankly a majority view on almost every
controversial issue i mean really
genuinely from like abortion to climate
change
there is a majority view that can be
reached to actually move the country
forward
but we can see the extremes are actually
holding us back and i would say
that this is the most genuine
pro-democracy effort i've ever been
involved in i mean we're not going
around the united states looking to
invest in races
where we're going to take out you know
unifying moderate leaders from the
democratic or republican party that's
not what this is about this is about
going to introduce choice and
competition especially in races where
there isn't an alternative especially in
races where you have an extremist on the
ballot and no one who can defeat them
that's really where we're going to be
investing a lot of our time is going to
give people choices in those races where
the only choice they have is a really
bad one or two really bad ones so i'm
excited about this the energy is
enormous across the country uh and i'd
love for folks to come join us so people
should go to forwardtogether.org fwd
together and uh come be part of the team
well miles it's great to be on this team
with you brother team america it is
uh we are just getting started on what i
know is going to be an incredible
journey uh but again hats off to you for
doing so much for the country for
showing character
uh and
integrity in the face of a lot of
adversity and pressure not all of us
could have done it uh and we appreciate
the heck out of you for for taking it on
i appreciate you my friend thank you
andrew let's go fight the good fight all
right thank you forward let's go forward
and i'm gonna fly again
you